[Musique]
pascal est assistante familiale depuis
six ans à l'accueil des enfants en
situation de danger se bat pour leur
offrir une éducation mais aussi un foyer
chaleureux où ils peuvent s'épanouir
accueille trois enfants ils ont
c'est un jeune majeur de 19 ans le
deuxième il a 17 ans et le troisième il
a 8 ans l'un journée type j'en ai un qui
est au lycée c'est à dire que bah il se
lève très tôt lui se prépare
il n'y a pas de j'ai pas besoin
d'intervenir on va dire par contre celui
de 8 ans ben je me lève sur le réveil
petit déjeuner douche je lui donne aussi
sans goûter pour l'école et puis bah à
19h45 on y va à l'école et je le
récupère à 15 heures l'après midi voilà
j'en ai un peu mais mois après à la
maison hantée c'est tout ce qui est
ménages si j'ai des réunions en dehors
pour le travail j'y vais ça va être
aussi les courses l'euro par sage voilà
tout ce qu'une maman fait en général
dans une maison voilà ce métier
d'assistante familiale s'est présenté
comme une évidence pour pascal qui a
toujours travaillé au contact des
enfants
j'étais dans une école j'étais dans une
école
primaires je travaillais en tant que
head a réussi on va dire un vin jeune
classe et en sortir de ce contrat avec
la mairie
je me suis dit pourquoi pas travailler
avec les enfants
savez vous que j'avais eu ce petit qui
était dans ma classe
celui qui à 19 ans maintenant il était
dans ma classe je m'occupais de lui et
il est venu en accueil chez moi donc ça
ça a été vraiment la preuve que ben il
fallait que je fasse un métier larmes
afin de permettre aux assistants
familiaux d'assurer au mieux les besoins
quotidiens des enfants accueillis une
indemnité journalière est versée depuis
janvier 2016 en plus du salaire pour
chaque enfant confié c'était une
nécessité parce que souvent ils nous
demandent des choses et bien on peut pas
parce que la vie est chère à la réunion
37 % que de plus que la métropole
donc du coup passé 2,57 la de plus ça va
nous faire une petite augmentation de
environ 80 euros
eh bien ça va permettre justement de
leur acheter plus de choses c'est pour
rendre cet argent là des mesures de
contrôle seront mises en place par la
direction enfance et famille en vue de
s'assurer que les sommes versées
participe à l'amélioration de la qualité
de la prise en charge des jeunes
accueillis
[Musique]